a
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el dios simbionte no es un personaje
oscuro siniestro e imponente que poco a
poco se ha ido posicionando como los
personajes más fuertes que marvel nos ha
mostrado en años recientes pues además
desde el creador de todos los inventos
de la existencia y ser alguien capaz de
matar a un celestial sin problemas
es un personaje rodeado de misterio y de
muchas cosas que aún desconocemos pero
hoy vamos a despejar un poco de ese
misterio pues vamos a descubrir quién es
nube
ya oscuro eres que está seguro que no
eres del universo
quién carajos eres lula es un personaje
que ha participado brevemente en muchos
cómics y ha tenido ya varias apariciones
mostrándonos en cada una de ellas su
poder abismal ya sea dándole sus patadas
al silver surfer' o acabando con seres
superior mente poderosos como los son
los celestiales
[Música]
incluso tomando algunos de ellos como
esclavos pero de dónde vino este
personaje no es una entidad que existía
antes de la creación del universo cuando
todo era oscuridad y solo existía la
nada nuevo el vivió cientos de años en
esta oscuridad y él se adaptó a ella
considerándola como su reino pero todo
esto cambió con unos seres conocidos
como los celestiales llegaron a su
universo deshaciéndose de la oscuridad y
creando la vida en cada rincón del
universo esto enfureció a null pues los
celestiales no sólo habían destruido su
reino de las sombras sino que lo dejaron
enceguecido con la perpetua luz de la
creación no estaba furioso así que sin
pensarlo creó de sí mismo una espada
viviente con un enorme poder a la cual
llamaría la necro espada y rápidamente
atacó a uno de los celestiales
decapitando los sin problema alguno al
ver esto los demás celestiales
desterraron a nubla la cabeza cercenada
el celestial a un vacío mucho más
profundo
aquí usando la cabeza celestial como su
nuevo hogar nur se convirtió en el dios
de la forja además a través de su mismo
cuerpo y utilizando la necro espada como
catalizador crearía al primer simbionte
aunque claro dado que el momento de
crearlo el sol
de su martillo y el fuego de la forja
eran lo único presente desarrolló sin
quererlo las debilidades de los
invidentes el sonido y el fuego durante
mucho tiempo no perfeccionó su espada
convirtiéndola en un arma cada vez más
poderosa e incluso eventualmente creó
para sí mismo una armadura simbionte que
lo protegería de cualquier ataque
si el bosque macizo así que armado y
furioso no se dedicaría a recorrer el
universo destruyendo todo y a todos los
que se cruzarán en su camino y
extinguiendo poco a poco la luz que una
vez le arrebató su reino hasta que en
una de sus batallas no fue derribado
cayendo en un planeta lejano lo que le
dejaría en un gran letargo aquí un ser
conocido como war le arrebataría su
espada no finalmente despertaría y
eventualmente se daría cuenta que al
unir parte de su propio ser con otras
criaturas puede revivir las y darles
nueva forma controlando cada aspecto de
estos nuevos seres mientras se alimenta
de su fuerza vital al darse cuenta de
esto no él comenzó a unirse a miles de
series a lo largo del universo creando
así a los simbiontes nul podía ver a
través de sus ojos sentir su dolor y
saber lo que hace cada uno de sus
inviertes a lo largo de todo
el veía y sentía lo mismo que todos y
cada uno de sus millones de simbiontes
lo que le concedía un vasto conocimiento
pues funcionaban a través de una mente
colmena todos conectados y controlados
únicamente por el nouvel se había
conseguido un ejército con el cual
planea expandir su dominio en todo el
universo y volver a reclamar su reino de
las sombras pero cuando puso sus ojos
sobre el planeta tierra y en medio de la
edad media envió a uno de sus inventos
con forma de dragón para reclamar la
tierra toro ha aparecido para salvar el
pueblo vikingo y con un rayo acabó con
la criatura
esto sería fatal para nur pues debido a
que él y sus criaturas estaban
conectadas los rayos del sol también lo
alcanzaron a él causando que se rompiera
la conexión con los simbiontes y la
mente colmenas se deshiciera cuando esto
ocurrió cada uno de los millones de
simbiontes en el universo fueron
liberados del control de nul y
obtuvieron una mente individual luego de
esto los ambientes se rebelaron en
contra de su creador y decidieron
sellarlo en el interior de un planeta
artificial creado a partir de cientos de
miles de simbiontes llamado clienta por
mucho tiempo se creía que clinton en el
planeta de donde provenían los
simbiontes pero ahora sabemos que sólo
que un planeta creado para
tener sellado anula pues en el lenguaje
de los simbiontes clint ar significa
jaula miles de años después sirve
encontraría el cuerpo del dragón gestora
había derrotado muchos siglos atrás y
comenzaron a experimentar con él lo que
causó que accidentalmente despertarán
anula que era un seguía preso en el
planeta de los inventes hasta que
durante la historia de absolute carnage
no recuperaría el control de todos sus
ambientes y lograría salir de su prisión
después de esto comenzaría el evento que
en in black' en donde no luego de salir
de su encierro se dirige a la tierra
para invadir la con sus millones de
simbiontes acabando fácilmente con la
mayoría de los héroes más poderosos de
la tierra
como en nules una entidad supremamente
poderosa capaz de básicamente [ __ ] a
medio marvel pues no solamente es
inmortal sino que a lo largo de todas
sus apariciones a enseñar un set de
habilidades que lo convierten en una
amenaza para todo el universo marvel y
comenzando por su capacidad para
manipular el abismo viviente cantidad
que representa el vacío que existía
antes de la creación esta habilidad con
la que durante el evento de king in
black cuando sea entry trató de atacar o
le permitió manipular el vacío que vive
dentro de centro y así con gran
facilidad partir a la mitad a uno de los
personajes más poderosos de marvel null
también posee muchas otras habilidades
pues tiene una fuerza y velocidad
increíbles puede cambiar su forma a
voluntad y puede manipular cientos de
miles de simbiontes a la vez y usarlos
para controlar a sus enemigos de la
misma manera que lo hizo con un
celestial convirtiéndolo en su
prisionero y en parte de su ejército
pero de igual manera null también posee
una gran debilidad pues en pared de sus
historias ha demostrado ser invulnerable
a la mayoría de ataques a excepción de
una sola cosa la única cosa que puede
herir a null es la fuerza de la luz y de
la vida es decir cualquier tipo de
energía primor
para la vida como por ejemplo los rayos
del sol o la energía cósmica pero a
pesar de su debilidad nunca ni pasar el
tiempo se ha convertido una entidad que
sería capaz de suponer una amenaza para
todo el multiverso siendo uno de los
personajes más fuertes que marvel ha
creado en tiempos recientes es decir el
tipo como mataron celestial por si mismo
eventualmente esto lo sabían los seres
más poderosos de la tierra el tipo es
fuerte
ahora ya sabes quién es no y por qué
significa una amenaza tan grande dentro
de marvel esta entidad es un personaje
superior mente interesante que
afortunadamente a lo largo de varias
historias nos ha permitido conocer más
acerca de él y el peligro que representa
se conoce algún otro personaje ya sea de
marvel o decide el que quieres que hable
házmelo saber ya sean los comentarios o
en twitter por ahora cuéntame qué te
parece la historia de nuble el rey de
negro hasta la próxima
[Música]